I guess my old Hills friends at Hills
reunion
years in the making Audrina Heidi and
Kristin spilling behind the scenes feels
drama I hope you guys are excited
because we're getting yet another mini
Hills reunion on very Cavallari and like
the promo promises we should expect a
ton of behind-the-scenes drama because
Lauren Conrad is basically the topic of
conversation
the episode was seemingly filmed last
month when Audrina and Heidi went to
visit Kristin and Nashville now we all
know Audrina Kristin and Heidi's drama
with Lauren played out over the years on
the hills I don't really want to sit
back and watch Spencer music every time
I see what the club you're hitting on
other girls The Rocketeer elf and
Heidi's relationship with Spencer was
seemingly a huge part of why Heidi and
Lauren are no longer friends Spencer
coming I have no issues with anyone okay
so it is a little interesting the trio
would still be talking about Lauren
because well it's been almost a decade
since the og Hill series went off the
air so we have this bond for life it's a
very big deal but also we shouldn't be
surprised this is happening Kristin told
ET she was bummed she couldn't be on the
reboot of the hills that premiered last
year do you have a little bit of FOMO
not being a part of that reboot I mean
of course I would love to make a cameo I
can't because a very Cavallari yeah I
mean even just you know hearing the
stories from them now they're kind of
catching me up to speed on so yeah I
mean I would love to be part of it in a
small way at the time she also explained
how Audrina and Heidi might be able to
come on her show should they make a
cameo on your show at all
okay one thing called contracts you know
not as simple as just thanks
but back to the Lauren of it all she is
yet to even share her thoughts on the
hills reboot which by the way is gearing
up for a season two and she hasn't
talked to or even about Kristen in years
unfortunately we don't keep in touch I
haven't seen her in years
but no but I think it's really cool that
her store is there this is here we have
our pop shop for uncommon James and
Heidi's here so it sort of like every
world all of our worlds colliding
together which is cool and last year
before the hills reboot premiered we
talked to some of Elsie's former cats
they had this to say did you reach out
to Lauren by the way before signing on
to get her blessing or to sort of talk
oh I don't think anyone did no-one's
really talked to her since the finale I
know Frankie has but you know we all
would our complete separate ways Lauren
is a really close friend of Jennifers
and I I think she wants what's best for
us
I think she's that kind of person she
wishes me the best I think she has
anything against the show I think she
just she's moved on to bigger better
things I didn't talk to her um but I
feel like I talked to someone that knows
her and I think that she was still
really excited for us all to do it and
she's in such a different place in her
life hopefully she'll watch and be
entertained by it
yes no word on if Lauren watched the
hills or if she'll watch this upcoming
episode of very Cavallari but here's
hoping until next time I'm Katie Krauss
and bye for now
[Music]